new data from the dating app hinge
reveals that three out of four singles
around the world say they prefer to stay
sober
when dating more than half of them say
that they want to be in the quote right
state of mind while getting to know
someone logan yuri is director of
relationship science at hinge and she
joins us now because relationships are
not an art but a science yes absolutely
what is going on here because i'm with
paul rudd sometimes on that first date
you want to have a drink to loosen up a
little bit be your best
i totally get it we all benefit from
that liquid courage but this is a big
trend that's happening in all parts of
the country and around the world where
there's a shift away from drinking we
see that gen z is drinking less in
general they're drinking about 20
percent less than millennials were at
the same age and the pandemic helped us
go deep we got to know ourselves better
now we want to get to know our dates
better and it's easier to do that
without alcohol you don't want to wait
until the sixth date to see if you like
the person sober
well one one of the crew members here
who show him remain nameless jared over
there on the stage
that it's not because they're they're
not drinking but they're smoking weed do
you think that's true i have heard of
california sober and we did look into
that book in general
what chenzi is telling us is they want
to be in the right state of mind for
dating they're very into mental health
and part of that is showing up in a
sober and authentic way and so it sounds
a little scary what happened to the
go-to date but there's so many creative
data ideas that you can do that don't
involve going to a bar but a lot of our
gen z's on the staff and we do have some
are very skeptical of this data what do
you say to them i think this is part of
a greater cultural trend we see that
even compared to a year ago people are
drinking less in general and people feel
like they lost time they couldn't date
the way they wanted to during the
pandemic they want to make up for lost
time and part of that is seeing from the
beginning do i like you or do i just
like this cocktail nate brought up a
good point when we were talking about
this segment which is if you don't find
out what your your potential partner is
like when they drink until date six or
seven you might discover you got a spicy
partner
that's a good point yes you want to see
all aspects of them but what we're
really hearing from people is they're
about authentically connecting right now
and part of that is showing up and going
for a walk having a great conversation
i think that's nice i was gonna say what
are some sounds boring does it going for
a walk going for a walk without alcohol
nope but i was like exercise get a
chance to have a conversation i like
that idea what about i used to think
going to the movies was good going to
the restaurant does anybody do that
movies yeah i have an idea so is it a
terrible idea what are some ideas good
movies movies you sit there in silence
next to each other
dale you owe for two right now on date i
did let's talk about what makes a fun
date a fun date is something where you
have an experience you can connect maybe
there's an activity that takes the
pressure off so apply
like like an activity like going to an
archery class okay that's fun
right it's like your adrenaline is
flowing do you have a growth mindset do
you like to learn new skills and so when
you first think date you think to drink
minimum but let's throw that definition
of a date away and let's see how else
can i connect with you without the
alcohol well since nate says i'm over
two what are baby boomers doing
we're seeing that this trend is really
starting with gen z so when we look at
the ages of people the older the people
are the more likely they are to say of
course i want to drink on a date but i
think this trend's really here to stay
because i like doing it's about getting
creative yeah i like it too but axe
throwing i mean if you don't like the
person you want to get out of there and
you got five axes left in the bushel
there it's kind of hard to leave don't
just leave them
even if the date's bad and you don't
like the person at least you tried
something new and you had fun and so i'm
just really encouraging people think of
a creative new date idea it doesn't
happen i'm all for it yeah well congrats
because i know you got married two years
ago but you didn't really get to
celebrate until recently yeah so far so
good thank you so much yes my wedding
was this past weekend i don't know if
you all know it but we're on our
honeymoon right now okay congratulations
walk to a movie
are you already past the first phase so
get some drinks uh logan yuri we
appreciate you